und zwar habe ich heute mich wirklich
aufgeregt so aufgeregt dass ich fast
geplatzt wenn immer im kopf so furchtbar
finde und zwar gibt es jetzt in hörsälen
das ist jetzt wirklich keine scherze
sind keine fake news die erste uni sport
ungeimpfte studenten aus
ich habe das gelesen habe gedacht das
ist jetzt wirklich nicht deren ernst
also man hat ja schon die letzten wochen
und monate sachen world wo man gedacht
das kann ja nicht passieren einer
aufgeklärten gesellschaft wieder unsere
jetzt ist es soweit die erste uni sperrt
die umgebenden studenten aus es ist die
friedrich alexander universität erlangen
nürnberg und die führt ab montag die 2g
regel ein und lässt ungeimpfte studenten
gar nicht mehr in die hörsäle rein für
mich ist es ganz klar wir dürfen auf gar
keinen fall in deutschland eine
impfpflicht haben aber wenn ich so was
höre hagen besitzer eine impfpflicht es
aber völlig konträr zur freiheit und ich
weiß dass dieser satz ist einen gewissen
pathos beinhaltet aber wer für die
impfpflicht ist ist gegen die freiheit
ja das erscheint mir doch ein ganz
kleines bisschen verkürzt vielleicht
hatten also vor allen dingen ich glaube
dass die argumentation eine sache fehlt
nämlich sie sagen jetzt ganz einfach
diese freiheit vergessen aber für meine
begriffe dass es externe effekte geben
kann und ich glaube was wir im
augenblick noch als allgemeines narrativ
sozusagen haben auch bei solchen
universitäten das ist dass jeder
einzelne der ungeimpft ist gehörten
immunität verhindert das ist ja noch
eine geschichte die uns vor einem jahr
ungefähr erzielt worden ist das wenn der
wert nur weil können runter geht nämlich
dadurch dass alle geimpft sind dann
stirbt das virus ganz von alleine aus
und wir kommen alle raus aus der nummer
wenn das so wäre dann würde ich sogar
sagen wie er dann im pflicht völlig
angebracht weil es dann nämlich
tatsächlich eben von einem einzelnen der
nicht geimpft ist ein ganz starker
negativer externer effekt auf andere
ausgeht nur die geschichte hat sich als
falsch herausgestellt es ist ja gar
nicht so und deshalb müssen wir glaube
ich dieses narrativ einfach bei uns
ändern ja ich glaube es muss aus vielen
köpfen raus dass es mit der
herdenimmunität sowieso nicht klappt und
infolgedessen solche regeln tatsächlich
völliger burg sind vor allem ist auch
super gefährlich weil zum beispiel auch
droste hat darauf hingewiesen diese
dieser satz immer es ist eine pandemie
der ungeimpften der ist falsch wir haben
immer noch eine pandemie und vor allem
schade dieser satz auch weil wir müssen
ja weiter auf die wohlhabenden gruppen
achten und auch wenn ich jetzt keine
virologen bin lasse ich mich jetzt zu
einer these hinreißen eine junge frau
anfang 20 die nicht geimpft ist
wahrscheinlich weniger betroffen auf der
intensivstation zu lang als wenn sie
ende 80 gar nicht mehr geschützt werden
altersheim und co irgendwann lässt das
stück noch nass oder einem anderen thema
alter auch dann wenn wir uns anschauen
wie die dieses land verteilt als auch
von den altersgruppen her wir sehen doch
ganz klar wer im moment stark betroffen
ist was die zahlen nach oben schießen
lässt das sind vor allem die fünf bis 14
jährigen das ist aber klar sagen hat in
verschiedenen bundesländern sind die
ferien vorbei das erklärt schon mal sehr
sehr wir war symptomatisch offen wir
müssen jetzt schauen dass man auch
dieses differenzierte denken einfach
beibehält weil das letzte was wir
brauchen um auf deine these auch zu
kommen ist eine weitere spaltung der
gesellschaft weil wir haben sie schon
wir haben sie ich befürchte wir merken
es manchmal schon gar nicht mehr
bemerken nicht mehr wie weit wir schon
sind wenn wir diese diskussion
weiterführen dann führen wir auch diesen
weg weiter und ich glaube das ist gerade
in anbetracht der tatsache dass wir eher
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt brauchen
das absolut falsche signal ganz
unabhängig davon noch wichtiger keinen
weiteren lockdown unsere betriebe sind
kaputt geht man hier durch berlin es ist
doch jetzt schon soja restaurants hotels
auch in den besten lagen wenn ich jetzt
schon höre das jetzt wieder diese
drohszenarien aufgebaut werden und der
nächste loch ist schon wieder in sicht
und wir brauchen jetzt unbedingt diese
impfpflicht damit wird argumentiert
vergeht da kaum noch hören und sehen
einmal bewusst oder unbewusst eine
gegenthese zu formulieren ich bin auch
gegen die impfpflicht aber gerade wenn
du über freiheit sprechen und sagen die
impfpflicht würde zur maximalen
unfreiheit führen stelle ich mir doch
auch die frage wie viel verantwortung
eigentlich diejenigen haben die sich
nicht impfen lassen und ja ich würde
ganz kurz jahr da die schließlich
natürlich von einem aus aber ich meine
jetzt mal die die bewusst auf
verschwörungstheorien möglicherweise
reingefallen sind oder ist aus anderen
gründen auf gar keinen fall machen
wollen unabhängig von denen wo es
medizinische ursache gibt gehört ja auch
zur wahrheit dazu dass diejenigen die
sich nicht impfen lassen dass es dazu
führt dass die freiheit derjenigen die
sich impfen lassen wieder massiv
eingeschränkt werden könnte wenn wir uns
eine situation gerade anschauen in
portugal zum beispiel oder auch in
spanien oder auch in italien da ist die
impfquote wesentlich höher und da ist
das risiko dass es wieder zu einem
lockdown kommt wesentlich geringer aber
warme länder aufgelistet teilt das darf
man ja ich glaube so die begründung
dadurch wissenschaftlich immer wieder
höre zu zu impfquote ist dass sie damals
schrecklichere bilder dort gab und sie
selbst erlebt haben also soldaten auf
der straße waren das sozusagen wie
erlebt haben was für ein horror stehen
da will ich die leute die das machen
weil du hast ja jetzt gegenthese zu mir
gesagt als geimpft der macht doch ein
ungeübter gar keine angst also warum ist
der ungeimpften ihr gegenüber unser nie
daran keine angst sondern ich meine
unsolidarisch insofern als dass das zur
entscheidung führen kann die dann wieder
das gesamte land am ende ein es gibt
einen ganz wesentlichen punkt den wir
noch gar nicht angesprochen haben es
gibt dann immer noch so etwas wie eine
verfassung oder ein grundgesetz oder wie
man bezeichnen wie und die diesen
verfassungen und das ist in der
deutschen verfassung im grundgesetz auch
so da gibt es ein paar grundsätze zum
beispiel gibt es da einen grundsatz also
die gibt's bei uns ich nehme und da gibt
es auch bei euch gewerbefreiheit
bewegungsfreiheit ein recht auf
körperliche unversehrtheit wo ist denn
eigentlich das recht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit wenn der staat faktisch
befehlen kann und hier eine bestimmte
medizinische behandlung zu verabreichen
meine was ist meint dass das natürlich
auch noch punkte meine wie die politiker
freihändig über solche hirnen
verfassungsgrundsätze dahin vexeo de
weck bretter die wegpunkte sind da setze
ich ein großes fragezeichen
und ich sage immer dass wir wissen seit
dem alten testament die menschheit neigt
dazu periodisch immer wieder den
falschen gründen kälbern hinterher zu
rennen und im moment huldigen alle dem
gott der sicherheit und dem gott der
gesund sind haben erwähnte werden
zermahlen kommen unter die räder und zu
meinem großen entsetzen er wird jetzt
auch noch paul rom sein nein zu einem
advokaten dieses vermeiden also immer
als bullen also den
qualifikationen wo sie haben wir das
gefühl ich bin das ich habe hier mal
bewusst die banker aufgemacht weil die
ja in deutschland gerade geführt wird
und ich will da noch mal widersprechen
das ist ja gerade die kritik die
angesprochen
aktive rolle bei der vorübergehenden
regierung vor der wahrscheinlichen
regierung ist ja die ist ja die kritik
massiv aus der cdu aber auch aus der
gesellschaft aus den medien von bild
jetzt nicht aber von vielen anderen die
sagen dass es unverantwortlich dass die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite überhaupt beendet wurde also
dass man dieses monstrum ähnliches mal
für beendet erklärt hat und so zu sagen
so ein lockdown gar nicht mehr so
einfach wäre verriet wie erleben sie
dass die debatte gerade in deutschland
also ich möchte gerne auf einen punkt
hin weise nämlich diese zweig regel ist
ja gerade eine die die verbreitung des
videos nicht verhindert das muss ja auch
mal klar
ja ich meine das heißt dass sich die
leute die verbreiten können nicht testen
lassen müssen und denen die auch
besonders unvorsichtig sind also weise
sicher sicher fühlen weil sie geimpft
sind sind auch gleichzeitig liegen diese
in wahrheit am stärksten verbreiten das
heißt also wenn wir die verbreitung über
stadt befördern wollen da müssen wir
genau die zwei gierig wobei wir auch
sagen können dass viele eltern nicht
funktioniert hat nur fünf prozent haben
bislang eine booster impfung man sagen
kann dass der impfschutz gar nicht so
wie wir uns versprochen das stimmt nicht
also darf ich mir die zahlen angesehen
und der impfschutz ist relativ gut also
dass sie ist eine sache da muss man
bedingte wahrscheinlichkeiten angucken
das tun die meisten nicht und wenn sie
nicht als bedingte wahrscheinlichkeiten
google sieht so aus als würde die
impfung nicht wirken tatsächlich ist sie
aber ähnlich von der wirkung her so wie
versprochen also etwas schlechter das
gebe ich zu liegt also bei 80 prozent
bei den 95 aber sie liegt jedenfalls
schon so dass sie hilft aber nochmal
diese zweige regel erfüllt nicht das
ziel von dem er behauptet wird dass es
erfüllen sollte nämlich dass die
verbreitung verhindert und der info ich
meine ich habe das als geschenk von ich
gebe es auch offen zu ich hab mich
redlich bemüht er sich schnell einen
impftermin kriege ich war
ganz schnell ich habe
wir waren ja dankbar dass wir die
impfung bekommen habe ich habe mich
darüber gefreut auf den tag auf den 2
ich verstehe gar nicht warum wir in der
gesellschaft immer alle so schmackhaft
machen müssen du musst du musst du musst
ich glaube wirklich wenn man die leute
die so in die enge treiben würde die
können ja schon fast gar nichts mehr es
dürfen nicht mehr in die hörsäle für die
es auch selber mal nach ein paar monaten
auch sagen ich möchte es doch aber wenn
wir die immer in die ernst schreiben
werden ja auch extrem rasch tanz dadurch
werden wir wollen wir schaffen damit ja
auch dann plötzlich paradoxe situation
weil die gefahr an keiner stelle mir
sichtbar also dadurch wenn wir sie immer
runter drücken sozusagen die gefahr dass
überhaupt irgendwie geht ja aber den
log-dateien da wird sie nirgendwo
sichtbar und dadurch entsteht natürlich
bei allen der eindruck da sowieso alles
komplett überflüssig das heißt also wenn
wir sie einfach mal sichtbar werden
lassen würden im kleinen dann bin ich
mir auch ganz hier würden viel mehr
leute noch zur impfung gehen weil wenn
man so ausgerechnet also ich sage ich
mich die ersten heute nicht geimpft hat
und jetzt würde ich so ausgegrenzt weil
dann will ich irgendwann sagen jetzt für
mich gar nicht vorstellen ohne
losgewesen werden unterstrich dass
trainer das wir
glauben